Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, ich
begrüße Sie herzlich zur heutigen Pressekonferenz
des diesjährigen
Verteidigungsministertreffens der Central European Defence
Corporation and the Western Balkans.
Ich bitte die österreichische
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Turner und den stellvertretenden
Verteidigungsminister der Tschechischen Republik,
Daniel Blaskovich, dazu  kommen Sie mit auf die Bühne
Ausland
Ich bitte die österreichische
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tana um ihr
Statement
Danke liebe CDC-Kollegen liebe
Kollegen vom Westbalkan
Exzellenzen meine Damen und Herren
Ich freue mich, dass Sie alle der
Einladung zu unserem CDC-
Verteidigungsministertreffen gefolgt sind  Hier bei Spielen in meinem
Heimatland Österreich
freue ich mich auch ganz besonders, dass unsere
Freunde vom Westbalkan
an der Abschlussveranstaltung der
österreichischen CDC-Präsidentschaft teilgenommen haben und sind auch hier
heute
noch einmal ein ganz herzlicher Spaziergang an
alle meine Verteidigungsministerkollegen
hier hat Österreich den Vorsitz der
Central European Defence Corporation
du  Während unserer Präsidentschaft wurden zahlreiche Programme,
Workshops, Schulungen und
hochrangige Treffen organisiert,
immer mit den Schwerpunkten
Westbalkan, Kaukasusregion und zivil-
militärische Zusammenarbeit,
insgesamt 13 Veranstaltungen
2010 gegründete Plattform
und um die Zusammenarbeit zwischen den
teilnehmenden Staaten auf eine neue Ebene
zu heben auf eine praxisorientierte Ebene
projektorientiertes Arbeiten um das
Ergebnis der Ergebnisse unserer Zusammenarbeit
sichtbarer zu machen
bietet die CDC allen teilnehmenden Staaten
die Möglichkeit dazu  wichtige
sicherheitspolitische Fragen mit ihren
mitteleuropäischen Partnern erörtern und
gemeinsame Positionen auf EU-Ebene vorantreiben, um
nicht nur einen Beitrag zur
gemeinsamen Sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik zu leisten, sondern
auch um für mehr Sicherheit und Stabilität in Mitteleuropa zu sorgen,
stand die diesjährige Ratspräsidentschaft vor einem massiven Problem
Russlands  Krieg
gegen die Ukraine,
als wir die Präsidentschaft übernahmen  niemand
niemand erwartete angesichts des radikalen Wandels der
europäischen Sicherheits- und Verteidigungslandschaft, mit dem
wir heute alle konfrontiert sind,
angesichts dieses schrecklichen
Asphalts umso wichtiger war es für
uns, vom Reden zum Handeln zu kommen
und
vor allem den Blick
auf den Westbalkan nicht zu verlieren  Staaten,
die schrecklichen Ereignisse der letzten Monate
haben unsere Aufmerksamkeit auf die Ukraine gelenkt,
aber wir dürfen die Länder nicht vergessen,
die sich seit Jahren
um mehr Sicherheit in
ihren Regionen bemühen und die unsere Unterstützung brauchen,
es ist klar, dass
der Krieg in der Ukraine Europa verunsichert hat
und
Trotzdem
dürfen wir alle nicht ignorieren, was
direkt vor unserer Haustür oder an den österreichischen
Grenzen passiert,
wir müssen weiterhin für Resilienz
und Fortschritt auf dem Westbalkan sorgen, und
wir müssen unsere Westbalkan-Initiative weiter unterstützen,
und hier konnten wir arbeiten  Einige
wirklich konkrete Vorschläge, einer davon ist
das Western Balkan Stevens College, dessen
Arbeit dieses Projekt unterstützt  Unsere Experten
und unsere Soldaten, die seit Jahren
für Sicherheit und Stabilität in der Region sorgen.
Unsere Experten haben ein Papier verfasst,
das von der EU positiv aufgenommen wurde.
Es ist unsere Absicht, dieses
Projekt anzustoßen, das nur
durch die Finanzierung des europäischen
Friedens umgesetzt werden kann  Einrichtung
auf EU-Ebene
mit dem Western Balkans Defence College
wollen wir eine Ausbildungsbasis in den
Bereichen Sicherheit und Verteidigung schaffen, die
sich an den Prinzipien der Europäischen
Union orientiert
Ende Oktober hat
der Europäische Auswärtige Dienst
Möglichkeiten und Optionen ausgelotet
Region
bietet dieser Vorschlag die Möglichkeit,
die Widerstandsfähigkeit des Westbalkans weiter zu stärken
und ihm bei der
Annäherung an die Europäische Union zu helfen sowie
die Interoperabilität zwischen unseren Ländern zu verbessern.
Natürlich
haben wir während unseres Treffens auch über
das Thema Migration gesprochen,
das die Region betrifft  uns alle
besonders im Hinblick auf die
Westbalkanroute und die Staaten im
Südosten  Europa müssen
wir klar sein
Migration beginnt nicht an den österreichischen
Grenzen
wir müssen deshalb noch
enger mit unseren nachbarn kooperieren um
illegale migration gemeinsam zu stoppen
sehen sie
meine damen und herren
der cedc ist ein wichtiges format zur
stärkung der gemeinsamen sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik europas und  Die CD c soll
weiterhin durch gemeinsame Projekte und Aktivitäten zur
Stabilität und Resilienz
der Regional Securities im Westbalkan und in der Kaukasusregion beitragen,
und durch Dialogplattformen wie
diese kommen wir unserem
Ziel, ein sicheres Europa zu schaffen,
natürlich immer näher
viel Arbeit vor uns,
aber wir dürfen nicht müde werden, unsere
Ziele zu erreichen, und müssen uns weiterhin auf
das Wesentliche konzentrieren.
Vielen Dank an alle, ich danke Ihnen allen für Ihr
Engagement,
und hiermit möchte ich
dem stellvertretenden Verteidigungsminister,
Herrn  Daniel Blaskovich aus der Tschechischen
Republik, Gastgeber der cedc-Präsidentschaft
im Jahr 2023. Vielen Dank, vielen
Dank  Vieles, Frau Ministerin, die
Sicherheit Europas
basiert auf Zusammenarbeit,
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat nur bewiesen, dass
die Lieferung von Waffen, Ausrüstung,
Munition
[Musik]
und humanitärem Material
ohne die Zusammenarbeit der west- und mitteleuropäischen Staaten nicht möglich gewesen wäre.
Es ist offensichtlich, dass Putins Russland
versucht seit langem, unsere Einheit und
Zusammenarbeit durch verschiedene
Formen hybrider Einmischung zu untergraben.
Putin weiß, dass nur
ein vereinter und kooperativer Westen stark ist,
also schreitet er voran, er versucht, uns zu spalten
,
deshalb begrüßt die Tschechische Republik
jede Plattform, die diese
Zusammenarbeit vertieft  und CDC ist definitiv eine
dieser Plattformen
hier. Frau Ministerin.
Ich möchte Österreich für seine
Bemühungen innerhalb des CDC im Laufe des Jahres danken.
Sie haben wirklich großartige Arbeit geleistet. Ich möchte
Ihnen dafür danken und das kann ich
Ihnen während der tschechischen
Präsidentschaft versprechen  in der CD CDC werden wir versuchen,
unser Bestes zu tun, um diese Bemühungen, die
Sie gerade begonnen
haben, fortzusetzen. Wir begrüßen Sie auch  cdc konzentriert sich auf den
Westbalkan Der
Westbalkan ist eine der Schlüsselregionen, auf die
wir uns während der tschechischen Präsidentschaft
im Rat der Europäischen Union konzentrieren,
und da die Tschechische Republik
nächstes Jahr die cedc-Präsidentschaft übernimmt,
würde ich das gerne tun  Stellen Sie hier klar, dass
der Westbalkan
hier zu unseren Prioritäten gehören wird.
Wir sehen die Stabilität dieser Region als
äußerst wichtig an.
Aus Sicherheitsperspektive ist der
Westbalkan eine wichtige
Migrationsroute aus dem Nahen Osten,
ein Ort, der mit russischen hybriden
Aktivitäten verbunden ist
Region, in der Stabilität
nicht selbstverständlich ist,
unterstützt und wird die Tschechische Republik daher
weiterhin Bemühungen unterstützen, die
darauf abzielen, die Länder des Westbalkans
in die euroatlantischen Strukturen zu integrieren,
aber lassen Sie mich darauf hinweisen, dass der wirtschaftliche
und sicherheitstechnische Tisch des
Westbalkans auch eine Garantie dafür ist  unsere sicherheit
wir unterstützen die region seit den
1990er jahren, als wir anfingen,
zum mi zu beitragen  Missionen in der Region
und wir
tun dies derzeit weiterhin. Wir wollen
eine Einheit von bis zu 40
Militärpolizisten im Kosovo einsetzen,
die sich ab dem 1. Juli 2023 der italienischen Karabinereinheit anschließen wird
,
ähnlich wie
unsere Soldaten an der LTA-
Mission teilnehmen  in Bosnien und Herzegowina wurden
unsere Bemühungen in diesem
Bereich natürlich durch
den Ausbruch des Konflikts
in der Ukraine weiter verstärkt,
es hat deutlich gezeigt, dass wir
nicht in der sicheren Welt leben und dass Kriege
in Europa nicht der Vergangenheit
angehören  müssen daher in der Ukraine
Unterstützung
bewahren und bei der Unterstützung der Kampffähigkeit unserer eigenen Armeen den grenznahen Regionen viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit schenken und sie stabil halten
bewaffnete Konflikte sind
heute und jeden Tag bei weitem nicht die einzige Form der Aggression  die hybride
Aktion kann wirtschaftliche
Aggression beinhalten diese Informationen
kriminelle Aktivitäten
wollen aktivistische Aktivitäten gegen
demokratische Institutionen sein
usw.
es ist nicht o  Nur unsere moralische Pflicht,
instabilen Regionen dabei zu helfen, Worst-Case-
Szenarien zu vermeiden, aber es ist auch unser souveränes
Sicherheitsinteresse,
daher halte ich es für wichtiger, dass
wir heute offen mit
unseren Partnern aus dem Westbalkan
über aktuelle Sicherheitsfragen sprechen konnten
Idee,
das Western Balkans Defense College zu gründen Ich
glaube, dass dieses Projekt einen
großen Beitrag leisten kann
Ich möchte auch unseren Partnern
aus den Westbalkanländern für
die Beteiligung an den Missionen und Operationen der Europäischen Union danken
Abschließend möchte ich bekräftigen, dass wir das wollen  dass der
Westbalkan diesen Weg fortsetzt
, um eine sichere und stabile
Region zu werden,
es ist ein Weg, der nicht nur für
die Länder des Westbalkans und
die Sicherheit ihrer Bevölkerung gut ist,
sondern auch für unsere Sicherheit
im Namen unserer Frau Ministerin Hannah
I  möchte
Sie alle
nach Prag einladen,
das wir während unserer Präsidentschaft im CDC beherbergen werden,
und wir hoffen, dass wir dorthin gehen  eine tolle Zeit zu haben,
wie wir sie hier in Österreich hatten, also
vielen Dank Ausland
[Applaus]
vielen Dank für Ihre Ausführungen, meine Damen und
Herren, diese Pressekonferenz
schließt das diesjährige Treffen der Verteidigungsminister ab.
Ich hoffe, Sie hatten einen angenehmen Aufenthalt
hier in Österreich und ich wünsche es Ihnen  Dir gute
Heimreise Danke Abschied
[Applaus]
Danke
Ausland